here at MIT I I got my PhD here in the
green building 40 years ago it's nice -
nice to come back to MIT this is our
beautiful planet but after a nuclear war
it might look like this was smoke
covering the world from the fires that
would be started that that IRA just
described and this of course would
absorb sunlight block out the Sun making
it cold and dark at the Earth's surface
and the temperatures could get so cold
that it would be like wintertime in the
summer and this of course would kill
basically all the crops and the people
that didn't die from IRA scenario would
die of starvation this and this is
what's called nuclear winter now this is
a graph of the total number of nuclear
weapons on the planet it the total
includes the other seven countries but
the US and Russia have most of them and
you can see in the 1980s a nuclear arms
race ended why the Jonathan said it was
because of demonstrations in Central
Park that was part of it but part of it
was because scientists informed policy
Woodson and Burks Paul Crutzen got a
Nobel Prize in Chemistry for his work on
stratospheric ozone but he also wrote a
paper pointing out that there would be
smoke from nuclear war and then it might
cause climate change and the next year
both Russian and American scientists
calculated the climate response their
results agreed showing that their
temperatures would get very cold in the
next year I published a paper and in
nature and and covey it all did and then
the nuclear arms race ended and that was
now
one of the theories is that it was the
end of the Soviet Union but the Soviet
Union didn't end until five years later
long after the nuclear arms race had
ended now we scientists do our research
by running models looking at data but
historians do research quite different
way they asked the people that made the
decision so here's some evidence to
support my claim first of all the the
number is not zero by next year because
of the trees so the problem still exists
so Ronald Reagan said a great many
reputable scientists are telling us it's
such a war had just ended no victory for
anyone because we would wipe out the
earth as we know it if you think back to
natural calamities in the 1800s
volcanoes we saw that weather so changed
there was snow in July in many temperate
countries they call it the year in which
there was no summer now one volcano can
do that what are we talking about with
the whole nuclear weapon exchange the
nuclear winter and Mikhail Gorbachev the
other person that made the decision
models made by Russian American
scientists show that a nuclear war would
result in a nuclear winter that would be
extremely destructive to all life on
Earth that was a great stimulus to us so
that was part of this story the problem
is that it's not solved yet and so we
still need scientists to inform policy
here's a graph of the number of nuclear
weapons number of countries of nuclear
weapons as a function of time it was
growing about one every five years the
Soviet Union disappeared and three
countries Belarus Kazakhstan Ukraine got
them they gave them back to Russia but
then Pakistan North Korea so there are
many other countries now besides the US
and Russia that have nuclear weapons
here's one inventory sixteen thousand
four hundred and if you break it up the
US and Russia each have seven or eight
thousand and as we saw on the graph
previously the other countries have a
couple hundred what happens when you
drop a nuclear bomb I'm not going to
show you but bodies like IRA did I just
want to this is this is it's like
bringing a piece of the Sun to the earth
for the fraction of a second and it
starts fires this is a drawing done by
one of the survivors in Hiroshima on
what they remember
the fires and the smoke and this is what
he or she may look like afterwards all
the the city was up in smoke now here's
a cartoon looking at what what it would
happen after a nuclear war started in
this in the Sinai
so this nuclear winter was done in 1980
is about ten years ago Brian tune in
rich Turco met me at the American
Geophysical Union meeting and said
somebody asked us what would happen if
two of these new countries India and
Pakistan had a nuclear war what would
happen they'd each have about a hundred
weapons each and they're probably very
small weapons like the Hiroshima weapons
15 kilotons not the big ones that exists
now in the modern Arsenal's and Bryson I
said probably not much but then he went
and calculated how much smoke there
would be and five million tons of smoke
and I said well that's a lot who's gonna
calculate the climate response he said
well maybe we thought you would so
imagine imagine the scenario on the
Kashmir border there's a skirmish and
because of poor communication or
misunderstanding or panic and fear it
grew into a nuclear war people get
killed all on that border ever every
week or imagine what a lot of Americans
are proud of is us killing Osama bin
Laden if you're a Pakistani air defense
and you saw these military invasion who
would you think would be in vain you do
we risk a nuclear war by doing that so
the scenario we had is what if a hundred
fifteen kiloton weapons were used this
is much less than 1% of the current
nuclear arsenal the direct effects would
be horrible as IRA just described but it
would produce about five million tons of
smoke in the upper troposphere so we put
that into a climate model and here's a
graph showing where it would go
horizontally and we're ago vertically
this is the tropopause so it would go up
into the upper stratosphere and stay for
a number of years we did this with a
modern climate model for the first time
with the smoke would last much longer
than we thought before but spread around
the world and it would block out the Sun
so we calculated how the temperature
would change and here's a graph of
global warming that I spent a lot of
time working on
and it would have a rapid cooling and it
wouldn't be winter temperatures but it
would be one one and a half two degrees
Celsius three degrees Fahrenheit below
normal and this would be climate change
unprecedented in recorded human history
it'll be colder than the Little Ice Age
that was one climate model the NASA gets
climate model people say well you know
we don't trust models or that's so we
every model has its imperfection so
recently two other climate models have
done the same experiment one in
Switzerland and one at the National
Center for Atmospheric Research and all
three find the same result from only a
hundred fifteen kiloton bombs much less
than 1% of global nuclear arsenal now
Mike Mills did a nicer graphic that I
like this is a looking from the North
Pole to the South Pole where the smoke
would go and it would rapidly go into
the troposphere is where we live where
there's rain that washes out particles
but if you get it up in the stratosphere
there's no rain and it can these small
particles fall very slowly but they're
heated by the Sun and lofted so you can
see this has now gotten to July so in
the northern hemisphere it's it's heated
by the Sun lofted up here and then it
will go up there and it would stay for
more than a decade so this was something
that was only discovered by redoing
these calculations with a modern climate
model so then we plotted how the
temperature and precipitation would
change from these three different
climate models and so this is the
temperature over ten years would go one
to one to two degrees below normal
precipitation will go about 10% plus and
also this smoke of course absorbs
sunlight and heats the upper atmosphere
and it gets very hot in the stratosphere
and this destroys ozone and so you have
a lot more ultraviolet radiation
reaching the surface in spite of the
smoke more ultraviolet would reach the
surface and we worry about the ozone
hole in Antarctica and the spring but it
would be like a nuclear winter ozone
hole the whole world would have a
reduction of ozone with moral travel it
the most important consequence of this
or any other climate change is how it
affects our food
so we took these scenarios we put them
into crop models to see how it would
affect and we looked at the two
countries that produce the most food the
United States and China how it would
affect corn and soybeans in the u.s.
rice maize and wheat in China and here's
a graph showing for 10 years the
reduction of 10 20 percent 20 percent 40
percent of these different crops forced
by the results of these different models
and to summarize for the first five
years food production in the world would
go down by 20 to 40 percent you know
what happens when the price of food goes
up a little bit there was a drought in
Russia five years ago and the price of
wheat they stopped exporting wheat and
that produced the Arab Spring there was
the the price of food went up and the
price of food produces revolutions many
times so that's not correct so so you
can imagine people like us rich people
like us the price of food will go up a
little bit but people that aren't living
on the margin might be subject to famine
I res estimated one to two billion
people would die from from from famine
but it's much worse than that this is a
u.s. tried at nuclear submarine it has
96 nuclear weapons much bigger than the
ones I just talked about so each tried
at is a thousand Hiroshima 's and the US
has fourteen of them and that's half of
our nuclear arsenal and Russia has the
same size arsenal
so we said there were questions about
whether nuclear winter theory was
correct so we said let's go back and do
the the the a war between the US and
Russia so he used the now sub model and
we put 50 or 150 million tons of smoke
what could produce 150 million tons
the current arsenal could if you put one
bomb on each turret in the past where
there were so many bombs you you they
were all used up before
or they ran out of the Arsenal so this
this is a graph showing the smoke from
this scenario and this is the climate
change had to rescale the graph so
temperatures would plummet below the ice
age temperatures now before you ask
everybody asked this question yes this
would solve the global warming problem
I've even done a calculation of that the
idea blocking out the Sun is called
geoengineering and it's also a bad idea
not as bad as this idea but so what's
new a nuclear war between nuclear States
using much less than 1% of the current
arsenal doesn't have to be India or
Pakistan will produce climate change
unprecedented in human history such a
small nuclear war could reduce food by
20 to 40 percent for a decade more
ultraviolet radiation nuclear winter
theory was correct the current nuclear
arsenal can still produce nuclear winter
and the effects will last for more than
a decade do you believe me good
but that's only a model calculation
scientists like to check models check
theory with observations and of course
we can't do this experiment in the real
world so we use analogs we use things
that have happened that inform us about
parts of the theory I'll just mention a
couple of them volcanic eruptions this
is a beautiful painting of the volcanic
sunset after Krakatoa over the oslo
harbour the that monk remembered and did
he said the sky was screaming blood and
fire this is the Tambora volcano which
erupted twenty two hundred and one years
ago producing the year without a summer
Percy Bysshe Shelley Lord Byron Mary
Shelley were having their vacations on
the shores of Lake Geneva and it was
really cold and gloomy that summer so
they had a contest to see who could
write the scariest story and Mary
Shelley wrote Frankenstein inspired by
the climate change Byron wrote a poem
called darkness I had a dream that was
not all and which was not all a dream
the bright sun was extinguish'd and the
stars did wander darkling in the eternal
space rayless and pathless and the icy
air swung blind in
lacking in the moonless air Morin came
and went and came and brought no day and
then forgot their passions in the dread
that's this their desolation no Hartford
children to a selfish prayer for light
so I learned about this poem by Russian
scientists who were working on nuclear
winter in the 1980s it sounds just like
nuclear winter it was only about a
degree Celsius colder this is a poetic
license but so there are a lot of other
analogues we know that cities burn we
know that it gets cold at night you know
that it gets cold in the winter so what
have I done about it well Bryan and I
are working you know we wrote an article
called self assured destruction it's not
just it's not mutually assured
destruction if country a attacks country
B and country B doesn't do anything
everybody in country a would die from
the climate response from the from the
famine so if you say I'm using my
nuclear weapons as a deterrent you're
acting as a suicide bomber you can't use
them now as you know President Obama
President me a dead have signed the the
New START treaty which means we'll have
about 5,000 weapons next year but that's
not enough it can still produce nuclear
winter so only nuclear disarmament will
prevent the possibility of a catastrophe
reducing our Arsenal's that is a good
sign but that's not enough Carl Sagan
was a one of the leaders of the work in
the 1980s unfortunately he died
tragically when people asked him about
that he said for myself I would far
rather have a world in which the
climatic catastrophe cannot happen
independent of the vicissitudes of
leaders institution and machines it
seems to me to be elementary planetary
hygiene as well as Elementary preacher
patriotism so I think elementary
planetary hygiene demands that we
eliminate the nuclear weapons much
faster so how do you feel
it's kind of it's kind of depressing
isn't it so what do you do about this
I'm really sorry
as mark $0.20 denial and just a river in
Egypt it it would feel better to pretend
you didn't hear it and go on with your
day but I've worked to to try and get
rid of it so there are bands on
biological weapons chemical weapons land
mines and cluster munitions but not on
nuclear weapons so the solution is to is
to ban nuclear weapons now
and so as IRA said the open-ended
working group now is working to after
these three international conferences I
wrote an op-ed that in The New York
Times last month to try and warn people
about it but unless someone like you
cares a whole awful lot nothing is gonna
get better it's not thanks
I want to know about the southern
hemisphere you mentioned you showed a
lot of graphics which impacted the
northern hemisphere since they are
loaded with the nuclear arsenal so what
impact would be in the southern
hemisphere well there are no nuclear
weapons in the southern hemisphere so
but the smoke would would cover the
whole world it doesn't really matter
where the weapons go off because the
atmospheric circulation would cover the
whole world now it's not here is mostly
ocean and so it wouldn't cool as much as
another Nemus fear but over the land
there would still be the same effects
but if you want to go somewhere to be
safe probably New Zealand would be
better than in other places so I have a
question about the climate models that
were used in generating especially with
the 50 to 100 teragrams my response I
guess my question is do they also
account for ice albedo feedbacks yes
there yes their standard global climate
models that are used for global warming
and volcano simulation so they include
all those feedbacks yes okay now we did
a we wrote a paper that the suit would
fall out and cover the snow and ice and
lower the albedo and counteract that a
little bit and we did a calculation of
that it turns out fresh snow would fall
on top of it so that wouldn't be a major
factor but it would it would it would
have a small impact
the question was what human beings
become extinct is that the question
that's one question in part two is
social media I'm curious how many people
in here on Twitter and live tweeting
this I think it's hard to argue that
humans would become extinct after the
Toba volcanic eruption 74,000 years ago
which made temperatures that cold for a
couple years some he a lot of humans
died but but our species survives so if
you were in New Zealand and there are a
lot of sheep and fish and stuff and the
temperatures when cool is much probably
people that were smarter lucky would
survive so I'm not sure everybody would
die but it would be a horrible
civilization would die for sure
wouldn't you say this represents a kind
of mass mental illness you got your
right-wingers you know that the ones
that that you know make make all these
weapons and because just because the
Russians had is a lot more liberal
politics now we've got right-wingers in
this country you know and their
corporate leaders they're destroying the
whole system and the Democrats you know
they can't even communicate well enough
to be Republicans well yeah you could
characterize it that way I mean it's
it's part of the military-industrial
complex that Eisenhower warned us about
and some people make a lot of money and
their careers are based on continuing
the these these nuclear weapons there's
a trillion dollar modernization program
now planned in the US and the Russians
are doing it too but it's a much easier
problem to solve than the global warming
problem because the total amount of
money involved is much less and fewer
careers so we just need some leadership
President Obama can reduce our arsenal
without a treaty with the Russia he
doesn't need a treaty to have fewer
weapons and that would be a really good
way to show some leadership in the last
year of his of his administration
how does US military planning doctrine
evaluate the concept of nuclear winter
and the implications well it's all
secret so I don't know we've I've talked
to John Holdren the president's science
advisor can you please talk to the
president about this and and there's no
evidence that they know about this and
so we're trying to get the word out talk
to Andy Rebka and the science reporter
for The New York Times can you write
about our stuff in the New York Times
finally he got me in touch with the
retro report which is part of the New
York Times whatever happened to and and
tomorrow they're gonna release this
thing they did on nuclear winter so
maybe that'll get some publicity but I
still am very frustrated getting the
word out so um there have already been
thousands of detonations done for
testing purposes all over the world and
we haven't seen this kind of scenario
that you are modeling here so Troy what
is the difference between those
detonations that have already happened
in the thousands and the scenario that
you're modeling I don't think it's been
thousands but it's been a lot the tests
were not done by burning cities the
tests were done in the desert over the
ocean and remote areas and it's the
smoke it's the black particles and smoke
the three percent of I mean this this
carpets probably plastic it forms this
black cities smoke and so it's the smoke
that causes the climate change not the
explosions themselves and so be now in
world war two there were a lot of cities
burned in genocide Obama's not just
Hiroshima and Nagasaki but Tokyo and
Hamburg and dressed in a lot of cities
in Japan and the global temperature was
a couple tenths of a degree cooler four
five years after World War two and I
don't that may have been the effect of
the smoke from that it may have been bad
data during World War two were working
on that but they didn't actually burn
cities that's that's the answer are you
in conversation I suppose with the White
House is that somebody in the White
House with whom you're regularly
correspond so that's this gets out to
everybody
well I tweet I have a Facebook page I
write up in The New York Times I have a
TED talk I've talked to John Holdren
I've talked to Rose Gottemoeller who's
the president's
advisor and nuclear issues I explained
to her how he could reduce the weapons
no he can't I said yes he can George HW
Bush did it without a treaty so I write
letters to President Obama but he hasn't
written back he has not